what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so those people who are new to
Marvel Comics and who are watching this
video on too powerful for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are probably just
like who the hell is Nimrod assuming
that this video even Garner's enough
people that care to watch it anyway ah
never odd Nimrod is God Nimrod is crazy
powerful okay so in order to understand
Nimrod we need to wind the clock back to
Days of Future past so the idea behind
this story is different from the movie
that you guys saw at to a degree is a
little bit different the idea behind
this story was that somewhere along the
line mystique reformed the Brotherhood
of Evil Mutants and when she did she
used them to assassinate senator Robert
Kelley Professor Charles Xavier of the
x-men and more McTaggart who was a
friend of the x-men and a mutant
geneticist she's actually one of the
people who up to help to found new
mutants the idea behind this was that by
assassinating those figures mystique
wanted to basically make a play and show
people that mutants were not to be
trifled with the opposite ended up
happening what end up happening in a
response to this is that initially the
city president wanted to pass the mutant
Registration Act but the mutant
Registration Act was shot down by the
Supreme Court as a violation of the
rights of mutants because they were
considered US citizens when they were
born in born United States so that meant
that the the Registration Act was
basically scuttled in response to this
the city president reactivated the
Sentinel program now the central program
had been deactivated since the death of
all of our Trask and originally it was
supposed to have been handed over to
Stephen Lang in the main Marvel Universe
but in the days of future past timeline
it was just reactivated and when it did
this sentinels were basically sent out
to basically start tracking down mutants
in to contain and control them the
problem with this was that the Sentinels
began to grow autonomous which is to say
they became intelligent beings and what
they did is they rationalized that
because mutants are an offshoot of
humanity which is to say the next stage
in human evolution
at their base level mutants are humans
and so what this did is it set in motion
the Sentinels just following logical
programming and taking over the entirety
of North America now in the movie Days
of Future past you had humans and you
had sentinels working together in the
Days of Future Passed comic the signals
conquered everything humans mutants the
whole nine yards they were all basically
you know capture and they were thrown
into internment camps they would put
these collars around people's necks it
wouldn't they would basically neutralize
their mutant powers and in turn and they
would just kind of go forward until the
day they died now what ended up
happening here is that in the Days of
Future Passed timeline Jean Grey and
Cyclops had a
turning Rachel in this universe Rachel
gray had realized that there was a way
to stop the Days of Future past by going
back in time and stopping the
assassination of Senator Robert Kelly
professor axe and more McTaggart no the
same time he had a lot of other things
going on for example you had Wolverine
and the Canadian wilderness who was kind
of orchestrating the Canadian resistance
against the Sentinels remember it was
North America so you're talking about
like Canada and the United States and
then you had like various other factions
here and there who are working to rebel
and so on and so forth anyway what is up
happening is Rachel summers Kitty Pryde
Colossus Wolverine Magneto and storm
I think managed to debate basically
alarms are in Franklin Richards managed
to make an escape from The Sentinel
concentration camp and make their way to
the Baxter building which used to be the
home of the Fantastic Four
before the Sentinels killed a man almost
every other superhero on earth as though
the signals had basically taken over the
Baxter building because it was so
technologically advanced and then
modified it to just create a ton of
themselves cuz here's the thing that's
what made the Days of Future past so bad
is that the Sentinels it was a it was a
war of attrition there were just so many
of them they they weren't really that
powerful it's just there were so many
select if a mutant was spotted out there
in the wild
the Sentinels would send like 50 units
which would just be overwhelming force
and they would either destroy the mutant
depending on the level of the threat
they post or they would just capture
them and take them back to to the
concentration camps but the fact remains
that with this group having made their
escape they of course free themselves
from their collars and then what happens
is Rachel summers sends the mind of
Kitty Pryde into the past now while
that's happening there's also an actual
effort by the the rest of the group to
kind of destroy the headquarters of The
Sentinel base they're all annihilated in
the process they're all basically
totally destroyed they never stood a
chance on the first place if the
Sentinels knew they were coming but the
mind of Kitty Pryde goes into the past
and it basically warns the x-men of the
impending assassination and the x-men
stop it after that happens Kitty prides
mine leaves her past body and goes back
to the Days of Future past the problem
with this is that in Marvel Comics they
have what's called branch universe
theory and the idea here is that at any
given time a story that's depicted in
the future is the absolute future the
Days of Future past was the guaranteed
future of the Marvel Universe
until it was stopped then the question
becomes how do you come from a future
that never happened and so what Marvel
did is they made the Days of Future past
and alternate reality they said okay
so the Days of Future past still
happened but that's it an alternate
universe the future of the main Marvel
Universe is now that Days of Future past
never happened and so when Kitty fries
mind
to the future went back to the future no
pun intended when Katie provides mind
went back to the future then basically
nothing had changed as far as she was
concerned because she and Rachel summers
did not realize it was an alternate
reality and so trying their best to
basically Orchestrator I guess continue
this rebellion against the Sentinels
they ultimately came across this
prototype signal that was being
developed named Nimrod and where Kitty
Pryde and Rachel initially tried to stop
it Kitty Pryde was destroyed and Rachel
jumped back to the present day which
kicks off days a future present for
those two guys who know about that story
but the idea here is that with Nimrod
having been activated and realizing the
threat that Rachel summers posed as a
potential host for the Phoenix force
Nimrod followed her back now Nimrod as a
sentinel is crazy powerful and the
reason why I say this is because Nimrod
was designed to be the ultimate settle
he was a prototype created by signals so
think of like the t1000 from Terminator
2 created by Skynet crated by the
terminators it's a prototype that's
designed to be the most advanced version
at that point in time the difference
here is that what made Nimrod so
dangerous is that despite the fact that
he was a robot he had powers and things
like that what made Nimrod so dangerous
is that if you were a mutant and faced
off against him or even just like a
super-powered being you didn't have to
be a mutant per se but if you were being
with powers to face off against him
Nimrod would analyze your genealogy
determine what your power was and then
develop systems to combat it so if
you're Thor Nimrod would analyze Thor
and realize that the hammer Mjolnir is
weaker than adamantium we're I guess
kind of sometimes it depends on the
story but in termina murad would encase
himself in adamantium he would he would
automatically alter his physical body to
be that of adamantium and then the
hammer of Thor would be useless and then
he would turn around an augment himself
to give himself strength that superior
to Thor and then take Thor apart piece
by piece in the case of like Cyclops
if Cyclops fires off his object beams at
at Nimrod Nimrod will analyze Cyclops
realize that his optic beams are
concussive and Nimrod would alter the
physical structure of his body to make
it more dense so that when the object
last hit him that basically it wouldn't
affect him at all you know I know now
here's the other crazy thing - here's
the other thing that makes him so
dangerous
Nimrod can be defeated like he can be
technically beaten but Nimrod can never
truly be destroyed and the reason why is
because Nimrod will always reform
himself you'll have to like phase him
out of existence or like incinerate him
all the way down to like the smallest
form of matter
otherwise he'll reconstitute he's got
like a cybernetic version of Wolverines
healing factor basically he's got all
kinds of crazy powers he's a lot like
the fury now that I think about it he's
a lot
the fury from the old man Jim Jasper's
comics like a being that was designed to
adapt to everything he fought so if
those guys you saw the Days of Future
past movie imagine the signals like that
except that was never on now the
difference that the signals would
automatically adjust based on the powers
of a person with Nimrod like it's a
thinking feeling thing like he would
function accordingly and he was
autonomous so he could function in and
of himself now eventually at all changes
when Nimrod and mastermold were merged
together they go forward his Bastion
which is like a whole different thing
kind of weird you get into operation
zero tolerance and in different stories
like that but what we're talking about
here is a future Sentinel powerful
enough to adapt to anything now that
begs the question what happens if nimrod
faces off against like The Incredible
Hulk where The Incredible Hulk does not
have a finite limit to his powers can
Nimrod defeat Thanos or something like
that and Marvel Comics we've never seen
that we'd ever seen Nimrod fight Thanos
before so we don't really know we can
largely assume he could but the problem
with this is that the data-feature past
did not go on long enough for us to know
whether or not the signals had set their
sights on places beyond earth right like
in Days of Future past North America is
basically destroyed in a nuclear
bombardment and that eliminates the
signals in their entirety but we don't
really know if they were looking to set
their sights beyond earth and if they
were then whether or not they were they
were looking at like the capabilities of
Thanos or somebody along those lines if
I were a betting man I'd bet all the
money all the money in my pockets - all
the money in your pockets that Nimrod
could probably could not defeat Thanos
because Thanos was just so powerful but
that's what makes Nimrod so dangerous is
he'll always reform he can just
reconstitute himself from from damage
and he can he can alter his body's
physical structure and his various
powers based on who he's fighting at
that point in time not only that because
he's a sentinel he can also tap into
computerized systems so you're talking
about like a one-man army right like
let's say let's say Nimrod shows up on
earth in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and like the Avengers
so like Robert Downey jr. and Chris
Evans and like Chris Hemsworth you know
I'm like like with all his characters
they all team up to fight Nimrod they
would get absolutely annihilated I mean
they would they would be destroyed no
questions asked and it wouldn't be funny
would just be a massacre like you guys
thought Ultron was king Ultron's got
nothing on Nimrod like like in the
movies no way I mean like say like
Ironman shows up okay well then Ironman
get Steve Howard right it would be like
Punisher versus the Marvel Universe
right like when Ironman got locked
inside his own armor and died inside his
own suit of armor it's a craziest thing
like Punishers walking by the Ironman
suit it's like like they say it was they
say it was like three days or five days
before the screaming finally stopped
like Ironman
diet like he was just locked inside his
own suit and died there pretty messed up
but that's literally something Nimrod
could do just like tap into the into
Iron Man's armor like hack his suit and
then shut it down like Captain America
Pete whatever man he's got a shield he's
out the window Black Widow Hawkeye they
would get decimated no questions asked
the only people who would really seem to
be able to stand a chance stand a chance
in so far is like they would not die as
fast would be like Thor or The
Incredible Hulk
The Incredible hoax the only person I
might give the advantage to because the
Incredible Hulk got unlimited strength
so the only way for Nimrod to defeat the
Hulk would be to basically amp up his
physical strength to beyond where the
Hulk is at at that point in time but
never I cannot increase his strength
infinitely at least not to we're aware
of that's one of the things that belongs
to the Incredible Hulk and this unique
to him but again things kind of get a
little hairy here because when you look
at the Days of Future past story
the Sentinels killed The Incredible Hulk
so we don't know exactly how he died we
don't know if they killed him when he
was Bruce Banner we don't know if they
kill him when he was the Incredible Hulk
and they were just that powerful oh we
don't really know exactly how all that
went down we just know did they kill the
Incredible Hulk so again it's it's kind
of crazy but literally it's Nimrod the
ultimate Sentinel I mean just uber
powerfully just just crazy powerful each
other crazy think Nimrod can shape-shift
he can make himself look like a person
so they wouldn't even know it was Nimrod
the Avengers are like oh well let's go
find Nimrod guys and like they're
walking down you're walking around the
city of New York they could pass Nimrod
50 times and never know you know and
then he just like takes just takes them
all out you know individually Nimrod
could show up to Iron Man looking like
Captain America and then kill him it's
just one of those crazy things it's just
a crazy level of power for a robot you
know to be able to pull all that all
that stuff off but in any event without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
robb for if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]